3 morte à téhéran deux à tripoli en
libye tout assassiné selon le même mode
opératoire
votre voisine c'était la numéro 8 il
paraît que vous avez vu un truc c'est
lui qui m'avait comment elle s'appelle
esque vous êtes pire qu'un autre is in
casier judiciaire possession de drogue
outrage
on va vous envoyer quelqu'un qui va vous
conseiller
rania thé mais vraiment samir la dass va
décider de l'avenir de la petite
entre temps vous la prenez avec vous
tu as été condamné pour usage de drogues
des recherches et pour qu'il impute à
bazens fait maintenant à doc une chance
d'obtenir la garde de la petite dans la
conscience
[Musique]
la place de la femme est derrière
l'homme à s'occuper de ses enfants
[Musique]
j'avais tué